well as the valley continues to grow so
does the number of cars on our roads
some neighborhoods are some neighbors i
should say are upset of the habits the
drivers in the area of skyvis and alta
this is over on the far west side sally
jaramillo explains the concerns of that
area close to the red rock recreational
area
people living in this summerlin
community say they are extremely
frustrated with drivers speeding through
this four-way intersection and hope for
change before it's too late
several streets in this area where
people go a lot faster than the speed
limit reba rocket has lived in this area
for two years she thinks drivers have a
false sense of how fast they're going
because the streets are really wide
either they sort of slow but go right
through or they just
go right through the intersection
without even bothering to stop nate
glass lives in summerlin and agrees
people in this area kind of see
crosswalks as just optional or either
people blow right through them and that
was something eight news now was able to
capture just recently rockets says she
is doing what she can to change this i
did contact lvmpd's traffic division
had a phone call with them but never saw
any police presence after that a young
woman in her young 20s was flying down
sky vista
crossed charleston without stopping and
ended up getting killed in that
accident as well and adds one fatality
is just too many rocket and glass have a
message what maybe you could have gotten
away with two years ago you really can't
get away with that anymore my concern is
that your next story on the news is
going to be the child that got hit sally
jaramillo live local now